If x-bar increases, then the difference between x-bar and mu 0 becomes larger.
And therefore the t statistic becomes larger. That means the t statistic will
be out here more, to the right. And then that's evidence that the mean of the
population that x bar comes from is greater than this mean. If x bar decreases
goes the opposite way, then the distance between these will also increase but
in the opposite direction. x bar will then be less than this value whatever it
is. That means the t statistic will be way out here in the left. And then
that's evidence that mu is less than mu 0. And finally the further the value of
x bar from mu 0 in either direction. The stronger the evidence that they're not
the same. So when we're comparing x bar to mu 0, we center the t distribution
at mu 0. And then we find where x bar lies on this distribution. The further
out x bar is, the more likely that it comes from a population that has a mean
significantly different than mu 0.